just the little time spent with Hyatt
Eldeen and it's so clear that
these are very difficult days for
Lebanon she grew up in this Beirut
suburb and now she spends all her time
checking on the people hit hardest by
this financial crisis people like Madame
Alice and her family can become an
ambulance Tana cool
I got bellick and the kid are you mama I
wanted Hakeem outside the rain has
started Hyatt is constantly on her phone
more families with no money wanting help
and the Gaza Miranda Kerr comin by
the family only live a few streets away
every day my auntie's house to house
like this there's no more than five or
so hours of electricity here and that's
if they had the money to pay the bill
for the Baha is trying to hold his
family and himself together the landlord
wants them out because he can't pay the
bill
let alone let me open the view container
that's about a hundred and eighty pounds
the children look okay but they're not
one has epilepsy and needs an MRI
another is diabetic if Baha had any
money it would be for their medicine
before the it is a snapshot of a crisis
that's bringing families across this
country to their knees on the other side
of town in a hospital that is modern and
looks well-equipped dr. George Gannon is
trying to juggle the shortage of funding
and supplies this is hitting every
sector the hospitals cannot afford
because this cashflow problem cannot
afford any more to treat the patient
their patient it means that the patient
can be started on some chemotherapy some
kind of therapy few weeks ago and now he
cannot in
receive this medication and this
specific hospital former Slovakian
foreign minister yang Kubus is now the
United Nations top official in Lebanon
for the next phase of crisis without
being addressed at my reforms will be
much more difficult the problems will
deepen and on top of that if the crisis
will deepen and will turn into security
crisis then of course we will have not
only those Syrians that are still in
droves if you wish as refugees but many
others and starting with a Lebanese that
would simply try to escape this this
kind of social strife that's it they're
back on the streets madam alice is
collecting her tin cans she'll make a
couple of dollars a week this way Mark
Stone Sky News in Beirut